so is everybody because I had this
conversation with Gary Vaynerchuk okay
and I said Gary like do you think
anybody can be an entrepreneur and he's
like no what do you think absolutely
they can not 100% by the way you got to
realize this
I think Gary's dominating the
marketplace right now you think about
the marketplace I think he was just on a
cover of entrepreneur he's been a cover
of Inc social media he's a rock star
when he about social media linked to
Gary so there's got to be respect on the
flip side of it yeah he took a business
from 3 to 60 million mm-hmm okay and
that's a big number but somebody took
the business from 0 to 3 million right
right and that's his father right so she
had the opportunity to see right
somebody that's winning big yeah he
witnessed that yeah so that that's that
here if you want to go out there do the
social media side I know nothing about
it right there he's got a big mouth
we've got the New York spirit in it yeah
yeah you know he comes out he's got the
immigrant fire in him and it takes off
now you know he also says a lot of times
that on the opposite side my mom and dad
loved me and they give me poured a lot
of love into me I mean you got I think
that's one in a hundred when your story
like that most families you're here
about parents got a divorce
that wasn't Iran they have mama issues
they have some kind of thing that they
grew up that wasn't necessarily the best
type of relationship but I believe
anybody yeah can be an entrepreneur's my
anybody can be an entrepreneur however
yeah however I will tell you however
part how big is not everybody can build
a massive business this is the world of
capitalism a stem from competition if
there was no leaders bulletin nobody
would follow baby I would much rather
communism the capitalist you would much
rather like communism thinking I would
not you rather comedy wife was communist
the country you know your go to
I was the ruler of the country the
ultimate capitalized I would watch and
whether the ultimate listen just for a
second control dude
is communist my mother's favorite
congressman these guys rank Karl Marx
they read they're like a bike because
your fares from the end of it well my
money my father was an imperialist my
mother said it would communist so you're
talking from talking about it from a guy
that lived in Iran their family escaped
from you know Russia to come because of
Stalin and Lenin and my dad escaped Iraq
with the Syrians to come to Iran so yeah
listen that makes sense if you're driven
by power
I'm not driven by power uh-huh power is
not something power comes easy to me I'm
not driven by that look at guys that
when during high school they come out of
college one guy decides to go into
politics right off the bat yeah it's not
driven by money is driven by power going
to business
he's driven by you look I just want to
have money so I can preach so I can live
wherever I want to be you know control
my whole life right communism is pound
capitalism is freedom so in capitalism
if you don't compete and you don't
improve someone's gonna whoop you no I
agree with that I agree with that
I mean but that that's not communism or
capitalism that is just a life cycle if
you're not getting better but but in
communism you can't compete there is no
competition you can no you cannot
compete huh
under the table yeah you do know that
the table should I don't know about all
that hell I know what I'm talking about
that's why I bring you guys when is
somebody ready to go to be a boss how
did you know you were ready to be the
boss
I think it's backwards man I I don't
think it's what are you ready I think
what are you solving for cuz then what
do you what what are you solving for so
huh solve for X what is X X is never
just being a boss this is it's a number
it's a lifestyle it's a place you want
to live it's control it's those things
so if you're solving for that it doesn't
always make sense I don't a lot of guys
that are employees that worked for some
big companies in the world yeah he was
never ever ever CEO
well he was a CEO but he never worked it
was not engaged when he di daddy gave it
to him so instead of saying like there's
too many of these boss boss boss boss
boss stuff going out we're about he
wants to be a boss what are you solving
for you know cuz a lot of times grant I
mean you know this I'm sure you got
sales guys here that they work with you
so to have an experience are gonna
they're gonna be able to learn and it
can make a lot of money working with you
then they date a girl or they have a
boyfriend a girlfriend yeah or a husband
or wife yeah they go home at night and
they say you know I can't believe you're
doing this why don't you go and do this
and yeah they go up and they try to do
their own thing and then they fail and
then they call you back in and they come
back and there's a lot of those stories
and don't call me back and I think a lot
of times it's because they're not
solving for us I think I think they do
have excess like you said hey I want to
be my own guy I want to make the money I
want the freedom and I think that's the
problem but this isn't always the route
to get there's not always the way you
think Iverson stayed in Philadelphia for
his entire career you never won a
championship uh-huh so what are you
solving for are you solving for a
championship what are you solving for
huh well so what should have gotta be
solving for I've never heard the animal
yeah to me I mean you asked me right now
take sales and put it aside if I were to
tell you what is the number one quality
of a person that goes straight to the
top is learning how to process issues so
assess is she processing issues
processing issues to me is solving for x